I was browsing the David Pakman show
subreddit this morning at david
pakman.com slash read it and a number of
people very very concerned about what
they believed might have been a head
injury that i suffered and someone
actually taking a screenshot from
yesterday's program and there was a
moment where there appears to be what
could be a gash could be a scab but
actually was just a little flap of hair
and we can leave that up pat oh nice
zoom in i like that for people and
although it did look like i might have
hurt myself all that happened is that my
extremely vigorous gesticulation because
of my passion for some of the issues
that we were discussing it dislodged a
few strands of hair and they splayed
across my forehead and that's all that
happened and i've been able to fix it
during the commercial break but no head
injury to speak of and I do appreciate
people being concerned but it's just a
little bit of hair that's pretty
terrifying I think I'm gonna need the
rest of the day off actually well this
is worse than when Pat allowed me to do
an entire show with borscht an Eastern
European style beet soup on my face
under the pretense that it was a pimple
that he didn't want to embarrass me
about and in fact I ended up doing an
entire show with beet soup on my face
this I think is not as bad as that no
probably not no that was everyone it
happens to the best of us yeah also from
our reddit discussion forum an
interesting post about governor mary
Fallon fallin I don't know how she
pronounces her name I guess it's Fallon
who likened Oklahoma teachers asking for
raises two teenagers wanting better cars
and this was not exactly her most um
articulate and enlightened comment about
the state of teacher salaries in
Oklahoma and things not going very well
for governor mary Fallon at a discussion
taking place about that on our subreddit
also from the david pakman show
subreddit in response to the caller jeff
from david's video caller says russia
didn't hack the DNC the transfer speed
conspiracy has been debunked yeah I
didn't know this so for people who don't
even know what the hell this is about
last week during live calls a guy called
in and said David it's been debunked
that Russia hack the DNC because of an
article in the nation that said the
transfer speed of
files means it couldn't have been Russia
I had never heard of it before and
immediately after the call I googled it
and it's been widely debunked like
incredibly widely debunked and the
reddit post made that very very clear so
yeah Jeff was completely wrong about
that and I'm guessing we'll probably
hear from him again and also from the
David Pakman show subreddit david pakman
show needs a tag line to give viewers a
clear idea of what kind of show it is
and some of the options that were posted
as possibilities for a David Pakman show
tag line were a progressive step forward
looking ahead progressive news one step
for man a progressive leak progressive
leap for mankind' us I don't even really
understand that one hey tree it's love
to hate us welcome to reality may cause
an allergic reaction for trumpets and no
we aren't commies since it is a common
thing that people mistake this program
for a communist or socialist show I'm
not gonna lie I don't love any of those
options I'm open to the idea of some
kind of slogan but I don't think that's
that's one of them if we already have a
tagline you can see it in the intro of
the show it's always like political
progressive independent media now it's
not very clever but it's something to
start with I'm open to tagging the David
Pakman show with some kind of slogan but
it's got to be better than the ones
proposed so far but you can put in your
two cents at david pakman.com slash read
it